Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Slime Rancher. Now
This is the full release of the game. This isn't in early access anymore, this isn't in Beta, this isn't a demo and that
avatar is actually really cute! :D
Ohhh, look at the style of that one. So slime rancher is fully released.
But I don't intend to do a full series of this,
but I do want to play a few episodes of this because I really did enjoy the game,
It just didn't seem like there was a lot of content there, so going back into it
I'm ready to see what they have from the very start.
This is game
Markimoomoo rancho reAl guuuuud  :33
Okay, save icon is-
DooDle doDle dodlDLE DoodLE DooDLe--
OHH dA chiCKeN!
Oh hell yeah, is that Markiplier over there? Okay
"Adventure: Live the life of a slime rancher and explore the far wonders of the far far range at your own pace."
"A mad Sprint for the most new bucks you can earn in five days bragging is encouraged."
I'm down for that... Nah, but I *sigh*
I kind of want to explore my own pace here,
I really do, I kinda wanna explore my own pace.
"1 and 24 characters"? Alright, how about Markimoo rancho real guuuuud? How about Markimo rancho real guuud?
How about Markimoo ran- how about r-rl guuud? There we go. That's the winner there. Alright.
Euh, wha- what slime is that?
"A thousand light years away from Earth." Oh my God, plot. "on a planet known as the far far range,"
"Beatrix LeBeau begins her first day as a slime rancher." Am I Beatrix? Am I Miss LeBeau?
Am I LeBeauPlier?
So this all looks relatively the same. Oh, you're gonna get sucked!
Sorry. Ahh,
That's the nice shit. That's the good shit. Get me-! oh
That's nice
"How to vac like a rancher: Your vacpack can vac things up and store them in the vac tank. Hold right mouse button to vac."
Oh, I think I know how to vacc. I know all about the suck and the blow of slime rancher.
All right you bastards let's see-
*fart*
All right, what are you gonna do. Can you take, Shroop de doob. Alright, I remember. Eat this *pfft*
Eat it! Eat it and grow big!
And give me your money. Give me your poop!
Ugh, the sweet slime poop. That's everything I've ever wanted. "You've vac'd a slime."
*fart*
Yay, I got munz.
Well, I've already done this, so I'm gonna do it again just so the tutorial can be happy about its life.
Hey, you! Slimo Boy! Get over 'ere. I need to get more rare slimes later, but for now you're gonna do.
*fart*
Alright. You don't escape now. What are you doing over there? You gonna get in your vat! boink.
Oh, you hesitatin' 'cause you bashed your brain up against the silo? No, ain't gonna do that. Alright,
I gotta go get slimes, or I gotta go get vegetables for you to eat, you little ungrateful bastards. I probably should have-
Probably, I probably should have- yeah, probably should have planted those crops. Oh look more crops! Scoodlee doodlee
Thank you. Scoodling to you. Come here, you. Come here.
I got a vat that you guys want to get in. You guys want to get sucked into my vatpack?
No no, sorry, your whole family's in my backpack. You can't escape from that.
You don't wanna run away from your destiny, do you?
Oh look, I got a pink slime on my house.
I don't think I put that there. Whatever.
*Huh duh doy de du dok*
Can't have too many of you. Here, eat one- two, two carrots, and I'm gonna plort it up over *boink boink boink...*
YAY!
Alright, I can plant me some carrots. *pft* No- That is not how that works.
I forget how that works. Why am I talking in Southern accent? I don't even remember.
Purchase, yay! *Poit poit poit poit* Oh, okay, never mind then. I only needed one.
I thought I needed more than one, but apparently I just need one. So while that's growing,
I'm gonna go out and get more booby-doos and they're gonna do this- What is this?
Hello? "Hello Beatrix! The name's Hobson Twilligers: rancher, explorer, and the former owner of this here ranch you call your own."
"Pleased to make your acquaintance. I was a rancher for more years than I can remember,"
"And felt there was one last adventure left in me, so I've set off to find just that. But before I go,"
"I'm taking one last tour around this here land I love."
"So keep your peepers peeled for notes like these, if you want to hear what an old coot has to say every now and again."
"Be talking to you!" Alright, fine then. Alright so- oohh! They're coming out of the ground! UHH!
Suck 'em up before they suck you!
Alright, get in my belly. Oh!
Money cat! What? Money cat?
What-? What are you? I don't know what you are.
Want a pogo fruit?
Well, that's dead now. There was nothing I can do, wouldn't get sucked up. I got star mail. I'll get that later.
Oh, hello. Well then. I uh...
Not exactly ready to have you on board just yet. Oh I got BOOPED!
They gave me an a-chav-ment. Oh, that's so sweet of them.
I don't know what it means, but I got one! Oh, is that a chickadee? Oh well, no, can't do that just yet.
I'll get a chicken farm later,
But I got to get- I got to start from like meager beginnings at first, and then grow later into my girthy more robust farm.
"You acquired a slime plort." I know what a slime plort do, buddy!
I've handled more poop than you could put your eyes on. So don't even think that you can tell me how to plort it up.
I'm all about the poop market these days. Oh, no, you can't get out.
Yeah, that's right because that's how that's supposed to be. Just eat and shut up!
Eat your goddamn pooping food and shut up.
Alright yep. I know I know, plort it up. Gimme gimme. Gimme all your plorts. Okay, you did good.
You did good. Could use some more poop next time, but hey, beggars can't be choosers.
So just get in there and stop being stupid.
Man, I sure am insulting my slimes.
Hey, you're all adorable and I love you!
You're doing great at whatever it is you do every day, which is just smile eat and poop, which frankly you know hey,
I wish I could live like that. Let me see if I can build another garden here, and then I can build...
Build a pogo fruit boober. Maybe this tip will be happy about that.
Oh, *euch* I don't like the way that bulbosates!
Don't like that at all, that felt weird. So I don't have enough- I'm gonna put you all in there.
I know you guys are gonna be assholes about it
Be a bunch of douches. You just take that food, you eat up. I'll be back. Alright. Don't go nowhere.
I know, I know, it covers the basics. I get it. I'm a smart.
I'm a smart! I got smart brains in my smart face! I got a big ol' head in my aside in my b-brain.
*burp*
Come here you, chickidee, "Chickadoo!" - oh, it's not a chickadee its a chickadoo!
Oh! Look at the kitty cats. Well, I got chickadees now. So I guess I'm gonna be going for the Tabby- *gasp*
It's a hybrid! What a weirdo. I can't suck you, you largo bastard.
*boink!*
Goodbye! *Laughs* See ya!
Alright, see ya! Alright well- Ooh, that's a valuable plort, a rock pl- OW! My ass~.
Well anyway, I've got a rock plort that's worth a bunch of this one,
but let me see what this guy's got.
"This entire cave system was sealed off from a cave-in when I first discovered it."
"Maybe that's why the fellers up ahead are so grumpy: haven't had a bite in a long time. In any case,"
"Don't let that long-awaited bite come from your own rump. Bring some food to calm them down."
Bring some food to calm whom down? ooh
What kind of plorts we talking about over-? *gasp* Ooh!
They're angry! Oh hi. Hey. I know! Okay, alright.
I am not okay with that. I will be back in just a jiffy, sir. Ooh...
*gasp*
WHaT?! Oh, that's awesome!
Oh, that's so cool!
I got the whole map now! Oh!
Look at me. How many secrets are there? Oh, it's huuuge!
Oh, it's Hu-gay. Oh, it's so much bigger. Man. I guess it has been a while since I last played this.
Jeez.
Come on, ya tabbies!
Come on. I said get in me. Get in, Alright, Im just gonna fill up on tab-ohhh, hey buddies. I'm gonna fill up on tabbies.
'Cause I want a full full assortment of taboos. Whoa, that was a- That was a male chickadee. I need you.
I need you more than I need a hen hen.
Ah, "Stony chick." Wait, no. What? A stony chick?
Oh, that's weird.
Oh, Hello, okay, alright. It's almost nighttime which means that the demons are almost here. Alright, I'm full on plorts there.
I had a great big tree like this here long. It's my property back on Earth
It has been there before anybody could remember it survived all kind of change around it and then one day
I began noticing it was dying wasn't anything unnatural as it said, it's time
I suppose, and then I realized that if I didn't do something. I'd end up like that tree
I spent my whole life in the same place
I'm going to let that happen, so I bought a ticket to the far far range the very next day
Oh, that's so lovely. I I marginally care
I think but I've got to get back before the nightmare is come and kill me meet all the other slimes
I mean what a life just happy smiling during the day and then nighttime
everyone gets eaten and killed and
Moidered, doodly-doo scoodly-me get out of my way before I kill you
Oh did need to I'm gonna feed that guy very soon the big old plort over there. Oh man
I miss having all my upgrades especially my jet pack and Whatnot but I'm gonna get there
Oooh, I got a chickadee over here. Oh that's awfully nice of you. Thanks for actually being there. Oh that's so sweet
gush...gush,gush,gush,gush,gushgushgushgushgushgush
GUShh, I need to build two more
I'll take you I need to build a chicken hen and more than anything cupe, okay?
Boink oh, I don't you think you can run for me? Hello. I didn't know i chiiickens here
Boink uh boink alright you grow up big and strong
Hope this doesn't hurt you anyway, alright, and then I'm gonna need a tabby later, but I don't want to get these guys intermingled
Give me your plorts
Give me your plooorts
Today get back in there you
Big bitch eat eat eat right in his mouth did I get an achievement for that just sailing right into the mouth of the phlegm?
Okay, there's that we've got 270 which is enough for another pen where I can put the tabbies in should be anyway boink all right
Get in there you tabby bastards. I'll have chickens for you when they're all grown up
Sorry mother hens your adoptive children are gonna be fed to the cat. Hey
IIII have no sympathy. Oh, whoa. What are you? Oh?
Look at you catch
You want to carrot, do you eat carrot?
Oh, you eat fruit. I don't have any fruit on me right now
Or else I would fruit you guys up ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Maybe I could go get some
To be worth it to go get some fruit. I don't know why the demons aren't attacking
Maybe they changed that in the story where they don't attack initially anyway
succ ohhhh
Hey you
Flying guys you want some fruit...boink hey?
NOM
Poop-poop for me thank you. That's a nice poop( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°). That's a quality poop right there hey. Oh you ate it over there
Well, you greedy piece of shit give me my fruit back you get OUT of here, you want some boink boink?
Don't give it to those goddamn pink slimes, not who deserves it
I don't have the money to build a pen for them or else. I would get him up, but don't need them right now
Hey, oh, why'd you blam blam on me? Yeah? Oh, that sounds bad that sounds like the bad music
Are we bad? Why are we bad? Why are we bad ladies and gentlemen? Why are we bad?
OHH, bok a bok a bok bok *chicken sounds*
No, no no no no no no no give no no no give me give me give me YeS roostro. Oh, hey
You're gonna make lots of ohhh, you're gonna make lots of babies moosetro
Let's go a little farther into the expo hi kitty cat. Oh, it's kitty cat. Oh, I'll get you later
I need to get the other grabow first. I think I need to get back I got rooster
oh, I got some good of these uh
These phosphor plots and sweet glowing poops. Which are worth way more than the pink ones, I believe oh
Hey, oh you are oh the tar ooohhoo
Okay, oh, there's the tar I was waiting for that to come around
God the opposite of the slime. I suppose, but still I don't know why they exist
oh, let me go ahead and dump all the rest of my fruit that I got along this guy hey catch uh
catch
Yeah, yeah
You don't even eat it anymore. You just absorb it into ya. That's somehow even more disturbing all right well, whatever
Roostro nah, im gonna keep this rooster. Don't even think about it buddy, and I'm such a dedicated farmer. No sleep for me
Just constant work no matter what?
No matter what gets in my way
Hey
You want to I don't have any more all right never mind then forget I said anything
In fact go fub yourself because I don't I don't even want to talk to you anymore
I don't even want you near my farm. You don't deserve to be here
uh, bep bep bep bep bep bep bep baow
Yeah, all right, then all right
Hey Roostro, no, this is where you die. Let me put in here point. Hey
procreate your rooster guy
Oh that means I can sacrifice one of you all righty, then Tabby well
They are liking those little they're liking those over there all right?
Anyway, I'll get you all right
Whatever that that king han is gonna have his fill but not from these hen hen sadly
the way Nature works all right doodle doodle doodle doodle...Fire!
All right, not bad not bad not bad okay. I think it's time to turn it in for the night
That was a good day. Oh
Look, how cute. I am star mail rise and shine. What's it like to sleep for a year
I think I got I got um I got these before so I think I'm fine sleep till morning
Yeah, that was fast anyway, so this is slime rancher
I want to play a few more videos of this, i wanna make, or uh i wanna play a few more*mark noise*
I wanna make a few more videos who this just because like it's really cool
And I want to see, like, the DEPTH, that it has now, just because slime rancher is such a weirdly like,
...
pleasant game it has like- I love farming games, like I loved Stardew Valley when it came out and I like these
these,
these relaxing farming games, but this one also has just an element of,
wEiRd mystery to it. How did you guys get out?
Did you guys get out?? Or are you guys just new? New cats in the area?
You sure are bouncy bastard (mumble) So anyway, so that is Slime Rancher for now,
I do want to make a few more videos of this and if you guys have seen more- HEY DON'T ESCAPE!
If you guys have seen more stuff to do in slime rancher, let me know down in the comments below
Thanks again everybody for watching and as always, I will see you in the next video. Buh Bye!
(nice outro music)(｡･ω･｡)♡
(subscribe to Markimoo!) ((no pressure tho))